- On this episode, we do it live, kind of,
from Wine Library.
(upbeat music)
♫ Gary Vee ♫
♫ You ask questions
♫ And I answer them
♫ This is
♫ The #AskGaryVee Show ♫
- Hey everybody, this
is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 177,
of the #AskGaryVee show.
We are at Wine Library,
which is a lot of fun,
you'll be catching some
of that on DailyVee,
I assume DRock?
In the dirty Jers, in
Springfield, New Jersey,
it's awesome to be here.
Brit, it's good to see you.
India still snowed in, or?
- She's sick, and snowed in probably.
- Sick and snowed in, double
"S's" for India, for 177.
So cool, really sorry I've
been traveling a bunch.
I know for everybody
that's worried or scared,
DailyVee is not a replacement
for the #AskGaryVee Show,
and so I just wanna
settle all those debates.
And I guess we should get into it.
- Cool, first question is from Shai.
- Shai.
- Hey Gary, it's midnight
here in Israel so I figured
I'd use this filter.
My question is, how do
you grow an audience
on Snapchat?
Do you have to go Facebook
and Twitter to tell followers?
- That was basically the
question, "how do you grow
"an audience on Snapchat?"
So Snapchat has no natural
in Snapchat app discovery,
which is f-ing with a
lot of people's heads,
because they're like "what the
hell, where's the suggested
"user list, where can I
search, how do I run ads?
"I can't grow," of course you
can, you grow the old way.
Pre-internet apps infrastructure,
you use other things
to grow your business.
I built this business using
a newspaper and a radio
and other things of that
nature, so the answer is
absolutely, I think he was going there.
I mean, watch my behavior,
it's not super complicated.
I'm using my Twitter,
my email, my Facebook,
my Instagram, to drive
awareness towards my channel.
I'm hitting up, I mean I don't
think I remember throwing
this many right hooks outside
of a book ask, which is
weird because I'm doing
that right now as well.
Dropping March eighth, go get it.
I've asked plenty of people
and they've sent me emails,
like "oh, you've really
helped my Snapchat."
These are historically emails
that I would reply to and say
"thanks, have a great day."
Now I say, "hey in your
next story, shout out
"my @garyvee handle."
I'm going in for the ask,
how about the bottom of your
email signature?
How about your user name on
Instagram, go look at mine.
You hack to build awareness for it.
You think about billboards
and print, where there's
no click or permalinks or
anything of that nature, no.
It's just awareness drives,
you didn't have to move,
it's got a wide angle, dammit.
I was trying to make you move.
- [DRock] I know.
- I was very impressed
with you there DRock.
That was a standoff that you
won, which pisses me off.
Where you drive awareness
to your handle, so yes,
any means of awareness,
I mean soon I'm gonna put
a sign in here that says
"follow Gary on Snapchat."
So yes, that's the answer,
using other platforms
to drive awareness to get
followers from that platform.
But scalable ones, email
signatures, your Linkedin account,
look at my Instagram
profile, things like that.
- [Voiceover] Kyle asks,
"When you are hustling,
"how do you spot the
difference between 'busy work'
"and 'valuable work?'"
- You know Kyle, that's a
great question, and honestly
that's a work in progress always to me.
Sam, real quick.
This is gonna be a real
live lesson in retail.
- [Sam] What's up?
- Please always make
sure you ask a customer
if they need any help.
- Oh I gotcha.
Yup.
- Okay cool, awesome, thank you.
Get out of here, get his handle.
So I think the, gotta shift
the brain from retail.
This is something I've
dealt with my whole life.
Like I don't think I've mastered it,
I mean I'm doing busy
work even now at the level
that I'm at.
I'm still doing busy work
that I think is in hindsight
not as good, I think experience helps you.
I think over time I've
learned through, "oh crap,
"I remember when I did
that back in the day,
"don't do that again."
You start understanding, but
I think one of the biggest
that entrepreneurs make,
especially as they grow
their business, or in the
beginning when they're crippled
by this thought of quality
work versus just doing it,
like smart work versus just
work, is when you start
judging it too much, you
start leaving yourself out
of opportunity for serendipity, and upside
that you can't see.
There's been a lot of things
on paper that might look
like busy work, just kissing
babies and shaking hands,
or just replying to everybody on Twitter.
Things that not everybody
think is the best scalable use
of my time that has
lead to enormous upside
because it wasn't obvious
when you first did it.
Including the video show,
including 10 years ago
in a month, sitting
upstairs doing a video show
where everybody's like
"we needed you that hour
"to sell wine, or to
reorganize our operations,
"why are you putting a video on YouTube,
"what is YouTube?" Like,
got it, it ended up being
the single biggest decision
of my career up to this point,
transitioning myself into a
media property and a brand
from just being an operator on this floor.
Wasn't obvious, felt like it
could have been busy work,
and there's been other things
that I've done like that
that have been busy work, trying
to think of a good example.
But like a million things
that we've stopped and started
that didn't become real, it
happens with us every day
and our team.
So I think that you don't always know,
I think you find out after
the fact, and I think to have
a long 40 to 60 year
old professional career
that's successful, as long
as you're learning in year
one, three, seven, nine, 12, patterns
start becoming more self
aware about yourself,
understanding your
strengths and weaknesses,
you start having less just
busy work, and more high
impact work, and that's
what's happened in my career.
- Next question is a Snapchat video.
- Gary Vee, my question
is, if we wanted to start
a subscription box service, should we buy
an email list?
Thanks Gary Vee.
- It's a great question, I
mean look, any time you start
any business an email list,
email is one of the great
ways to convert them.
The answer is yes and no.
Yes if it's a quality
list that has open rates
and click throughs, and
people that are interested
in your cookies of the
month club because it was
an email from cookie lovers.
But if you buy a list that
has a million people on it,
and it was part of a
photography list somewhat,
or just random emails that
they found around the internet,
and nobody opens it, and
they are into photography,
and you're trying to sell them
a cookie subscription thing,
the answer is no, that's a very easy play.
If you wanna buy a list
from somebody, force them to
do a test for interest around what you do.
Force them, "I will not buy
your list unless you do this."
And it's a presell to be on
the invite list for your up
and coming business, and if
you see a bunch of people
sign up for it, well now you buy.
Now they may say, that's
like selling the milk
without the cow, that whole thing.
You know, girl (mumbles).
Like I get that, but just
say no, there's a million
lists out there, you got the leverage.
They want your money, don't forget that.
- Good answer.
- That was good, right?
- It was good.
- There's some quality content here, Brit.
- There is.
- You mean like you were
impressed that that answer
produced that kind of quality,
that question produced
the quality answer that was
all encompassing for business?
- Yeah, I felt like I learned something.
- That's why the show exists.
- That's why I work for you.
- Thank you, go ahead.
- Next.
- By the way, love these snapchats.
- [Voiceover] Emojis and
URLS, and if you could have an
emoji what would it be?
- One more time, because I
was talking about how much,
thank you for everybody
sending Snapchat videos,
keep them coming.
And use Twitter to hit
up India, that was smart.
- Hi Gary, I wanna know
your opinion on the new
domain extensions emojis
and URLs, and if you could
have an emoji, what would it be?
- The new domain extensions,
what do you think--
- And emojis in URLs, is that possible?
Can you put emojis in URLs?
- We were Googling it right before.
- No, not yet right?
I think it's brilliant, I'd
be so into it, so into it.
My emoji would be the cash with wings,
because you know, I'm
always growing moneys.
- How to get your emoji URL.
- Is that real?
(mumbling)
So one, this is always fun for
me when I don't fully know,
is it available, like put that in.
- The product registered the first
corporate emoji domain back
in 2011, when it bought--
- Poop.la, right?
- Yeah, and it didn't do anything with it.
Simple, they can't.
All the big top domains
only allow normal characters
in their domain name.
- Got it, so look, let's
just assume that it's allowed
slash it's gonna be allowed,
I think it's gonna be huge.
Emoji is a language now,
period, end of story.
If you don't understand
that, you don't understand
the world.
Like we used to draw,
just because letters were
introduced doesn't mean
we can't use things now,
it's just communication,
don't get romantic about how
you communicate, worry
about actually communicating
in the year you live in.
There's not a single 50
year old in America now
who hasn't sent an emoji.
There are 62 year old
dudes that are bald as shit
and don't know anything
about technology and can't
even open an attachment,
that have sent a poop
emoji to their grandchild, right?
Like, let's talk about
your dad for a minute,
not technically unbelievable.
Has sent emojis?
- Yes
- Correct, because
that's what's happening.
It's crossed over, it's
mainstream, it's accepted,
it's understood, it's pictures,
it's (censored) basic baby.
And so I think it's huge,
mine would be the dollars
with wings.
I'm not very hot on domain
names, I think domain names
are what you make them.
I have friends that are
obsessed with names,
I've talked about this.
Like what is does Google or
Facebook or Snapchat mean?
It means what you made it.
Like Vaynerchuk, people
are like, "you're so lucky"
I'm like, "let's relax."
Like I made that name mean
something, Vaynerchuk,
like it's about what you do
with it, and so I haven't
really paid a lot of
attention to what's going on
in that world, which is
why I didn't even know
if you could own an emoji
dot com, or what have you,
it doesn't look like dot coms work yet.
But I'm super into it,
I'm all about emojis,
I even dropped the "e" there, to like,
you know like, me emoji.
- [Voiceover] Rochelle asks,
"What are your thoughts
"on today's Tiwtter
executive 'exodus' news?"
- Rochell, I think
there's, I think that...
So I asked for this
question to be on the show
because I wanna teach
everything about optics.
Meaning, when a new CEO
comes in and then there's
this "huge exodus," a lot of
times it means the new CEO
has brought in the people that they want.
And they're respecting
people and letting them
leave on their terms.
I don't see, or these
people actually don't
believe in Jack's vision.
My intutition is, based
on Twitter's track record
over the last three to four
years, and I love Dick Cusam,
one of my best buds in business
and I saw him recently,
but results are results,
meaning it didn't go good enough
for him not to be excited
about the guy who invented
it to be back in place,
though you might not like
his personality, things of
that nature, but I hate when
the media's like,
everything is so negative.
Like when I buy a company,
and become a CEO of it,
because that will happen
in my career, and there's
an exodus, becaue big shot Gary is coming,
let me promise you, anybody
that I wanted to keep
would have stayed, because
I would convince them
that I'm coming to do nothing but good.
And maybe three or four
just wouldn't see it,
or they were best buds
with the former CEO,
or they're just tired.
But please don't get
caught up in the hyperbole
of there's a new CEO, we're
still witihin the year
of that new CEO, this is
common business stuff, period.
Like, this is what always
happens, so you don't know
if they were forced out or
they were left on their own,
I don't know, even though
I'm close to a lot of
the people involved.
Because when I read those
headlines, I poo poo them
because I am an actual operator.
I'm not confused by them, I
know what real business is.
Jack's come in, he's got a
different plan, some pieces
fit for that, some don't,
some people he might have
wanted to fit for that, decided
they don't fit for that,
it's just real life, it's
not some huge conspiracy.
I think that's what I think.
Like that's what it is, I
just wanted to answer this
question because I'm
stunned by how many people
just accept very basic
narratives, when if you live it
you know the real details
underneath, just like you know
anything that's in your world.
My world is business, you know the real,
I read headlines, I'm
like "oh," you're like
"no, that's what really happened."
Just like we've gotten
cynical to "leave of absence."
Did you see "Spotlight?"
- No.
- Okay, it was about the priest
that did sexual harassment.
- Oh yeah, I heard about it.
- Their official, when
they were doing bad things
was they got relocated on
assignment, or "sick leave."
"Sick leave."
So this "exodus" may
be on strategy, get it?
Question of the day, actually educate me.
Tell me something that
happened in your world
and how it's explained,
but what's really going on.
Could be some fun late night reading.
- I'll be reading it.
- Yeah, I'm going to Phoenix
tonight so hopefully,
oh actually this is airing tomorrow.
We're doing a little bit of
smarter cadence on the shows,
it doesn't have to go out immediately.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(upbeat music)